[Musique]
alors dans ces
langages qui charrie tant de mots qui
s'élargit qui seule assise selon le
territoire a laissé ce langage ils
changent on en train dans les villes
dans les rues changent selon les
quartiers et puis il y à un autre
terroir du langage qu'on pourrait
appeler le terroir sociale et rien ne
crée du langage en quelque sorte qu'un
métier
dans un métier dans le langage
professionnel il ya d'une part les terme
technique qui désigne les outils qui
désigne les gestes qui sont des choses
nécessairement très précises car sinon
on se coupe un doigt ou si on va en plus
à travers les termes de la navigation en
bas la catastrophe et d'éminents
ainsi par exemple
dans une vieille corporation qui est
importante c'est de la boucherie on
trouve un langage technique celui qui
désigne un même morceau de viande et sur
lesquels il ne faut pas se tromper que
les ménagères planès ou croit connaître
et puis il y a aussi un langage secret
qui est celui d'une espèce de faune
maçonnerie d'ailleurs d'offres en
maçonnerie m le mot masson qui était un
métier dans ce métier là aussi sonné des
langues secrètes et les signes secret
des gestes se paie et bien
bush et il ya aussi ce langage de la
corporation ce langage se fait
ne pas être compris des autres qui est
aussi un signe de camaraderie et qui est
une espèce de chaleur sociale cette
langue secrète débouchés s'appelle
lellouche est belle et il y a encore des
bouchers qui parle de l'ouche et m alors
sébastien alors il faut la lâcheté
[Musique]
j'adore la corde
talus va le siècle a déclaré c'est nous
et maintenant vos questions
non la poule au pot les champs mais
[Musique]
orly dimanche donne qu'est ce qu'on va
leur faire
alors bien c'est mal élevé ou un bordel
l'élan du bien en face à la maison ouais
maison ni ouais d'accord
non alors sur sundance ainsi qu'à ce
jour avoir besoin de beyrouth aub ouais
d'accord on baigne troque
[Musique]
alors qu'est ce que vous êtes en train
de nous dire
voilà c'est dit à monsieur t'as vu c'est
toi qui parle et il m'a demandé c'est ce
que la vie de monsieur lange une non il
est pas méchant parce qu'elle est fausse
mais tiéné clients
alors si je comprends bien
seul à en gach lellouche et même sexe
parler aussi pour qu'on comprenne ses
clients ne comprennent pas oui vous avez
vous avez beaucoup de choses ça veut
dire que beaucoup ne comprennent pas qu
est ce que vous avez à cacher non on n'a
rien à cacher c'est à dire pour me
servir bétille on dise non ce soir donc
l'union ils viennent ils seraient
contents quand il repart et qu'ils ne
viennent pas nous faire des reproches il
a mis dix ans à venir galloway ce que
vous avez appris à parler douchez blog
ça s'est passé avant de passer dans les
maisons puis il ya les anciens chefs qui
parler l'argot but est alors nous
entendant enfants ouais
c'est la vie surtout avec les anciens
mais s'avère d'être relativement facile
parce que par exemple les bouchers en
bouche est belle ça se dit louchébem
avons donc on renverse le mot explique
moi pour s'affranchir alors voilà
lellouche mêmes ou argot des bouchers
alors lellouche et même se fabrique de
la façon suivante le mont mouchet même
venir boucher vous prenez le mot boucher
vous retirez toujours un mot la première
lettre si cette lettre est une consonne
et 7 consomme vous allez la place et à
la fin
du mot alors d'embouché pour retirer
le 1er on va on va mettre un accent et
vous ajoutez alors ce b du début vous le
placez à la fin a et vous placer
toujours elle
alors loucher et puis un suffixe en oem
ou au rock ou simplement en est par
exemple vous avez en douce
en douce vous allez dire en quelque
chose en douce et bien ça donnera vous
retirez le le des ou le placer à la fin
vous mettez à elle en
loucedé ou en loose doc ça veut dire en
douce vous allez avoir le mot fou alors
le mot fourrés et passez le mot vous en
louchébem est passé dans le langage
courant
grâce à pierre dac et pierre dac qui
avait lancé le mot avant guerre dans
dans son journal l'os à moelle alors fou
alors donc le f ont eu est ce pas alors
vous allez le faire mais le mot en
bouche et ben de nouveaux loups
et puis le f
avec loufoque par exemple
ouais c'est ça bastien donc on peut
toucher parce que vous êtes je vais leur
donner encore beaucoup de bouche et qui
parle de nos chefs n'ont pas leurs armes
il y en a peut-être 10% qui est pas
moche ça disparaît mais pourquoi parce
que les anciens s'en vont et puis le
jeune ça va secouer a parlé
la russie s'est pas aussi parce
est beaucoup plus là voilà mais j'ai
l'impression que maintenant dans les
clients et où il a beaucoup qui sont
bons
de new holland de parler leur commune
j'ai des gars beaucoup de clients qui
comprennent alors des fois qu'on
pourrait parler entre nous sur un client
d'un an et que le client comprenait ce
qu'on veut dire alors par exemple si on
parle de la machine
vous êtes
[Musique]